toi tu as commencé à travailler avec
guillaume Pley en 2013 tu avais 18 ans
et tu étais très content d'obtenir un
stage donc c'était lui que c'est lui qui
tape en stage sur NRJ exactement c'est
ma première expérience c'est lui qui a
été voir c'est lui c'est JM que j'ai
rencontré pour la station qu'on vient de
voir exactement que j'ai rencontré pour
le stage donc du coup ça c'est fait j'ai
fait j'ai commencé ce stage au début ça
se passait bien il parlait pas trop en
tout cas il me parlait pas trop donc
c'était il y a 10 ans et donc j'étais au
standard pour que les gens comprennent
donc en général quand on est stagiaire
c'est comme ça qu'on commence en radio
et c'est vrai que j'ai foiré une
séquence parce que l'auditeur était pas
bon etc mais j'apprenais c'était ma
première expérience et du coup Guillaume
me dit trop rien et le lendemain il me
convoque on était dans un open space
faut s'imaginer qu'il y a NRJ c'est un
open space ou on travaillait tous au
quatrième étage il y avait l'équipe de
Guillaume mais il y avait d'autres
services donc on était devant plein de
gens et il me dit Yannick lève-toi donc
là je me lève et tout et il me dit en
gros
ta foiré la séquence etc donc évidemment
je m'excuse je me dis je lui dis
excuse-moi je suis désolé et tout et là
il commence à s'acharner sur moi en
disant mais regarde toi comme tu es
personne voudra de toi plus tard même
des petites radios locales ne voudront
pas de toi il commençait à rigoler de
moi à
que mon physique personne ne voudra
travailler de moi parce qu'avant toi tu
es beau gosse non mais avant j'étais
j'étais obèse je faisais j'ai perdu 60
65 kg donc faut imaginer je faisais que
140 kg j'étais pas du tout le Yannick de
maintenant non mais quand même et c'est
beau quand même hein
mais du coup je t'ai donc en face de lui
j'ai 18 ans je pleurais il continue il
continuait au bout d'un moment on passe
à autre chose du coup moi je me suis
rassi j'ai continué mon stage et je
voulais arrêter c'était ma première
expérience mais je me suis dit ce monde
des médias c'est un monde affreux je
vais pas avoir les épaules etc et
heureusement qu'après j'ai eu d'autres
expériences je suis parti sur Virgin
Radio à l'époque avec Enora la chance de
produire l'émission exactement alors toi
je vais te poser une question et toi tu
as travaillé avec moi d'ailleurs moi il
m'arrive aussi et je le dis je le mange
je franchement je m'en cache pas ici de
dire voilà c'est de la merde truc les
gars vous déconner qu'est-ce qui me
différencie d'un guillaume Pley tu
pourrais dire aussi Cyril bah c'est vrai
Cyril il est venu moi on on s'est déjà
on s'est déjà tous les deux je t'ai déjà
dit Yannick franchement c'est une cata
franchement tu abuses non mais tu l'as
dit tous les deux on se parle on
s'appelle on se voit c'est pas en public
devant des gens lève-toi devant sa cour
devant des gens qu'on ne connaissait pas
c'est pour moi pour moi j'ai vécu ça
comme de l'humiliation mais ce qui était
quand même assez étrange c'est qu'au
début moi j'ai accepté le fait que ça
soit comme ça je me suis dit allez fais
le dos rond on continue de façon c'est
ta première expérience c'était en stage
dans ce métier on m'a toujours dit que
c'était difficile etc et en fait quand
je racontais cette anecdote aux gens
c'est là où j'ai pris conscience qu'en
fait c'était pas normal de vivre ça et
on se dit ouais pourquoi au bout de 10
ans d'un coup tu viens balancer ça etc
j'ai aucun intérêt à faire ça en vrai ça
va plus peut-être m'apporter de problème
de dire ça que de pas le dire mais c'est
juste qu'en fait au bout d'un moment
c'est pas parce que on fait un métier un
peu extraordinaire qu'on est obligé
d'accepter des méthodes qui le sont non
mais tu vois qu'est-ce qui moi je vous
dis même à Guillaume de lui dire des
trucs voilà ou à Yannick non mais je
vous dis on va pas je vous le dis des
fois par contre dans tout le monde il
m'est arrivé dans un studio de dire les
mecs c'est de la plein de trucs c'est
vrai je le dis la bosse dit la vérité tu
le sais c'est vrai voilà donc qu'est-ce
qui fait que lui il est border et pas
moi
déjà la première chose c'est la fidélité
guillaume Pley il a jamais gardé ses
collaborateurs moi je vais dire mais moi
il me l'a fait à l'envers est-ce que
voilà parce qu'ils étaient toujours à
bout vous la toutes les personnes il y
en a plein de claques qui sont là depuis
5 ans depuis 10 ans vos collaborateurs
en production aussi donc il reste donc
mine de rien la fidélité ça veut dire
quand même quelque chose si vraiment on
est à bout au bout d'un moment on part
et la deuxième chose moi Guillaume ça
fait 15 ans que je connais c'est que je
n'ai pas entendu et je connais peut-être
30 personnes qui travaillent avec lui il
y a un consensus dans le métier pour
dire que c'est un femme de travailler
avec lui que ce soit les patrons les
stagiaires les collaborateurs donc au
bout d'un moment moi je suis contre le
lynchage quand il y a un témoignage
parce que vous faites attention on en
parle on verra aussi moi voilà moi aussi
je l'ai appelé je l'ai insulté voilà
mais moi aussi
on parle aussi de de d'une équipe
composée que de stagiaires pour garder
tout l'argent pour soi de de
comportement très compliqué vous savez
de quoi on m’accusait aussi pour vous
dire moi par exemple voilà quand je
lance une émission par exemple quand
j'ai lancé quand j'ai lancé je sais pas
moi Camille à l'époque c'est moi qui
avait trouvé le nom de l'émission il en
pense Camille c'est moi qui avait trouvé
le truc donc ça donc je fais un truc
c'est vrai que je dis on partage les
droits d'auteur et et les mecs et des
journalistes qui m'ont dit ouais mais
quand on se fait que tu partages les
droits d'auteur parce que tu n'écris pas
sur l'émission mais c'est moi qui
trouvait le concept c'est moi qui fait
l'émission aussi l'émission